vous
mettez un vieux sac à merde
saloperie dont on dit oui
[Musique]
pourriture son billet je vais tous vous
ouvrir le cul
[Musique]
c'est mon film je vais bien ta gueule
tu me fais chier depuis le début des
répétitions alors malheur du bien ta
grande gueule de con
[Musique]
on continue de tourner alors atteint la
caméra
[Musique]
laurent il verra chirat muriel 10 1 est
soumis et anaïs elle devient chine à
sous et moi je suis kent
[Musique]
par contre rigole pas non non et je te
jure ne m'a pas ce match 18 les grands
mecs
[Musique]
tu m'étonnes que je suis chan
moore
[Musique]
ah ah
j'ai pensé à un truc mortels ah ouais on
va rajouter des sons des sound gratte tu
vois le gratin
[Musique]
ouais des trucs qui grince pour donner
un côté mystérieux flippant à tous à 3
grâce auprès des grincements ouais
parce que tu as dit gratin oui mais des
trucs qui grattent qui grince quoi tu
penses que je vais dire au revoir
tu vois ce que c'est un gratin
[Musique]
avec flippant génial
génial
[Musique]